[Music]
here we go
we are going to stop thousands
wow look at us we're adorable Mexico
come on Mario our big adventure begins
now oh I got this no problem
that is a cruel twist of fate you are
gonna help me find my brother Luigi
there's a human do you know him do you
think I know every human being with a
mustache wearing a magnetical outfit
with the letter of his first name on it
because I know
to the biggest fight of Our Lives
[Music]
classification
Bowser is coming together we will stop
uh who's he
[Music]
space is amazing
princess has been training them for
shield human I'm not threatened Mario
asked for it
is
your brother has landed in the dark
lands they're under Bowser's control
hang on Luigi
is
[Music]